it's been almost 2 months since Apple
released their new M series of chips and
they are amazing machines we have been
testing and using them but there's still
one question that we have not answered
that you guys keep asking us about
obviously the M3 Max is very powerful
but with that it's not a true comparison
when we're looking at the M2 and M1 Max
because Apple upped the price by 500
bucks if you want to get the full
performance that they showed off so how
does the B
$3500 version that actually is the same
price as the M2 Max topspec actually
compare and it's interesting because
Apple actually downgraded them in a way
if we look at the graphics cores we now
have 30 instead of 38 and if we look at
the ram well now it runs at 300 GB per
second instead of 400 that's 25% less
memory bandwidth now yes we do have 36
gigs of RAM compared to to 32 so that is
a small upgrade but it's just a
difference of how it is laid out and how
many chips require that now Apple also
changed up how much SSD chips go into
this machine and when we look at the
actual speeds they got faster
6,271 compared to 564 right now in terms
of the read speed they are very similar
so not a big difference there now as we
get into the CPU and graphics
performance I want to point out that the
the M3 is based on 3 nanometer and the
bend version actually has two more CPU
performance course compared to the
previous one with that said on screen
Apple advertised performance for the
164 actually seem to take a little bit
longer unless you're willing to spend
500 bucks more than you got in the past
now getting into single core CPU
performance we see a really nice
increase and that is because the CPU can
now run out 4 GHz slightly higher than
that compared to 3.5 so that is a nice
game and as far as multicore this is
where we have a massive difference
almost 20,000 compared to
14,000 that is actually
38% better performance and the crazy
thing is we are only using 177% more
power 40 WTS compared to 33 now I want
to mention that I will be talking about
battery life and a little surprise in
just a bit along with fan noise now as
far as graphics performance it actually
got worse with the version of the M3 Max
that cost the same as last year now that
is because of course we have less
Graphics course and that sucks and even
though we have less they are actually
using the same amount of power to get
this performance and looking at gaming
performance once again the M3 Max is
worse for the same price it is a worse
bank for for the buck now we do have the
ray tracing and some other improvements
as well and I'll give you those numbers
in just a bit for web browsing we do
have a little bit of an increase in
performance and I have to say actually
using them dayto day you cannot tell the
difference they are very close now if
you do tough 3D web browsing
applications like figma here smoothness
is all the same this project is brought
to you by 500 designs uh one of the best
studios in California and so you can't
really tell the difference in exporting
12 high resolution layers well yeah it's
a little bit faster but honestly that is
not worth it now getting into cinebench
which is going to hammer the CPUs we saw
a massive Improvement in performance I'm
talking about
50% faster and the crazy thing is we are
only using 16% more power to get 50%
more performance this is the kind of
upgrade we needed going from the M1 Max
now in terms of fan noise and
temperatures I definitely noticed some
differences at the end of this 10-minute
test both of them running at 102° C for
the hottest performance core but the fan
speed was about 1,000 RPMs higher for
the M3 Max version and you definitely
can't tell the sound difference the M2
Max you barely hear it but this one
starts to get a little bit annoying now
on a positive note if we're looking at
the temperatures of the CPU and GPU
block it is running quite a bit cooler
because of the higher air flow it's
ejecting more of that air out of your
laptop and I will tell you how to kind
of improve this in just a bit now using
Graphics to render in C bench the
difference is insane almost double the
performance because of the ray tracing
cores and this is where the M3 series
gets very impressive even the bend
version and even more impressive is that
it's using 25 watts instead of 30 to do
this because the ray tracing cores are
very efficient now if you use logic we
used the New Logic 2 Benchmark you guys
can look it up and we saw a huge
Improvement in how many tracks uh were
able to be played now there's other
things layered in here you guys can
check that out but that was very
impressive and a much bigger difference
than we got from the M1 Max to the M2
Max now for you guys out there that use
xcode we saw rough L A
40% difference and this is once again
very impressive obviously we saw those
differences in a geek bench and even
though we have slower memory for both
these applications well it definitely is
not hurting the system uh all the other
updates are making up for this and if
you use blender for rendering once again
we saw almost double the performance
very impressive even with the the bend
version so if we look at Graphics well
it was actually slower but for this kind
of productivity I mean this is a nice
Improvement so for people that do
productivity for all these various
things we just covered that is really
really nice now if you do video editing
like we do this is where things start to
shift exporting our standard h265
project with Luts and effects the speed
is identical because unfortunately we
don't have any new encoders and both
these systems have no issue with the
kind of editing we do you guys see we
have different graphs we have
screenshots we have b-roll including
some AK b-roll and they are the same no
dropped frames um it is completely fine
now I also wanted to test out uh
rendering a timeline this is what some
people say that they need to do and how
much faster is the new chip well it is a
little bit faster but not by much at all
and this is for almost a 16-minute real
world project that is heavy with b-roll
charts screenshots and a lot of
different footage now if you work with
prores I exported prores R prores it's a
5 minute project and the difference is
negligible they use PR decoders and
encoders they are the same that has been
the limitation and even going up to 8K
proes rer proes well the speed
difference once again is so minor with
that Den noising some Blackmagic raw
with temporal and spatial D noising both
actually got 24 frames per second and
the gpus were pretty much maxed out so
it's nice that they could do it but
there's no improvement and I guess that
makes sense because our graphics
performance as far as um in metal it was
actually slightly worse so don't expect
any Improvement and throwing the
toughest thing I could at it which is
Canon 8K raw we finally start to see
some differences once again it's not
insane but it is there so if you work
with red footage or Canon footage that's
raw where you don't have special
decoders for it yes you'll see some of
that Improvement uh but for everybody
else doing video editing we're really
not getting anything at all and that
kind of sucks so for us here at maxtech
it is not worth having the M3 Max
version It's kind of not a great update
now for photo editing here we do see a
nice Improvement 33% faster and as far
as the editing itself even for our
highresolution images um all the sliders
all that stuff is perfectly the same
they're both so powerful that you're not
noticing a difference so unless you're
rendering a ton of photos or exporting a
ton of photos you're not going to see a
crazy crazy Improvement and now let's
talk about back battery life because if
we're testing all of these programs on
the system and that usually takes 4 to 5
hours we're sitting waiting for a long
time it's pushing the system well at the
end of that the M2 Max well it had 5%
remaining compared to 20% on the M3 Max
Bend version that is actually an
impressive difference because even
though during our cin bench and a couple
other tests we're using more power a lot
of times it's getting done quicker and
that saves you battery life or for the
easier tasks it can use less power so
that is cool but looking at the overall
real world battery life we're seeing a
nice Improvement uh as far as heavy
tasks about 1 hour better and for light
tasks about 2 hours better battery life
and that is really really nice now there
also is a low power mode now I did a
full video on this going over the unbin
version you guys could check it out for
your interested but the crazy thing is
the performance even in low power mode
it beats out the M2 Max in full
performance and at the same time it runs
completely silent with the fans turned
off pretty much always and staying very
cool and that is because it only uses 20
watts to run geekbench so we have almost
half the power that is used same thing
for other tasks while maintaining a very
similar level of performance so if
you're trying to decide between these
two systems and you care about how loud
a system is how hot it runs well if you
want to use low power mode the M3 Max is
a killer because of the 3 nmet design um
that is a lot more efficient the better
efficiency cores and you're going to get
really incredible battery life along
with a lot of other tasks I showed you
we had some nice improvements but for
video editing especially and for web
based applications you're not going to
see much of a difference so if you can
score a great deal on an M2 Max and I'll
link a great deal down down in the
description below to Amazon I might
actually pick that up instead if you're
considering the same exact price point
now if you're willing to spend four
grand the performance actually shoots up
quite a bit and that one is nice but it
is unfair it's an unfair comparison
because Apple's making you spend more
money this year and that kind of sucks
so overall I like the machine I love the
new colors but um you got to spend more
money and for a lot of people it is not
really worth it you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one